we've talked about how vectorization
lets you speed up your code
significantly in this video we'll talk
about how you can vectorize your
implementation of logistic regression so
they can process the entire training set
that is implemented a single iteration
of gradient descent with respect to an
entire training set without using even a
single explicit for you I'm super
excited of this technique and when we
talk about neural network later without
using even a single exclusive full loop
let's get started let's first examine
the forward propagation step of logistic
regression so if you have M training
examples then to make a prediction on
the first example you need to compute
that and compute Z on using this
familiar formula then compute the
activation to compute y hat in the first
example then to make a prediction on the
second training example you need to
compute that then to make a prediction
on the third example you need to compute
that and so on and you might need to do
this M times of your M training examples
so it turns out that in order to carry
out the forward propagation step that is
to compute these predictions on all M
training examples there is a way to do
so without needing an explicit for loop
let's see how you can do it first
remember that we define the matrix
capital X to be your training inputs you
will stack together in different columns
like this all right so this is a matrix
that is a n X by M matrix so I'm writing
this as a Python numpy shape but this
just means that you know X is a and X by
M dimensional matrix now the first thing
I want to do is show how you can compute
Z 1 Z 2 Z 3 and so on all in one step is
act with one line of code so I'm going
to construct a 1 by M
matrix is really a row vector where I'm
going to compute Z 1 Z 2 and so on down
to ZM o at the same time it turns out
that this can be expressed as W
transpose the capital matrix X plus an
in this vector B B and so on beware this
thing this bbbbb thing is a 1 by m
vector or 1 by m matrix or that is is a
M dimensional row vector so developable
you are with matrix multiplication you
might see that w transpose x 1 x 2 and
so on through XM that W transpose would
then be a row vector right so this you
know W transpose will be a row vector
like that and so this first term will
evaluate to W transpose X 1 W transpose
X 2 and so on dot dot dot W transpose X
M and then when you add this second term
bbbb and so on you end up adding B to
each element so you end up with another
1 by n vector where that's the first
element that's the second element and so
on and that's the end
element and if you refer to the
definitions above this first element is
exactly the definition of Z 1 the second
element is exactly the direction of Z 2
and so on so just as X was what you
obtained when you took your training
examples and stack them next to each
other
stack them horizontally I'm going to
define capital Z to be this where you
take the little lowercase Z's and stack
them horizontally okay so we stack the
lowercase XS corresponding to different
training examples horizontally
this variable capital X in the same way
when you take these lowercase Z
variables and stack them horizontally
you get this variable which I'm going to
know by capital Z and it turns out that
in order to implement this the numpy
command is capital Z equals MP dot W dot
t w transpose x and then plus B now
there is a subtlety in Python which is
that here B is a row number or if you
want to say you know one by one matrix
was just a normal real number but when
you add this vector to this real number
Python automatically takes this real
number B and expand it out to this 1 by
M row vector so in case this operation
seems will be mysterious this is called
broadcasting in Python and you don't
have worry about the for now we'll talk
about this some more in the next video
but the takeaway is that with just one
line of code with this line of code you
can can calculate capital Z and capital
Z is going to be a 1 by n matrix that
contains all of the lowercase disease
lowercase Z 1 through lowercase Z M so
that was the hub of these on values you
know a write what we like to do next is
find a way to compute a 1 a 2 and so on
through a.m. or at the same time and
just as stacking lowercase X's resulted
in capital X and stacking means back in
horizontally locate these 2,000 Capital
Z stacking lowercase J's is going to
result in a new variable which we will
define as capital A and in the program
assignment you see how to implement a
vector-valued sigmoid function so that
the sigmoid function inputs this capital
Z as a variable and very efficiently
opus capital aids so you see the details
of that in the program design
so just a recap what we've seen on this
slide is that instead of needing to loop
over M training examples to compute the
lowercase V and lowercase a one at a
time
you can implement this one line of code
to compute all the Z's at the same time
and then this one line of code with them
appropriate implementation of lowercase
Sigma to compute all the lowercase s all
at the same time so this is how you
implement a vectorized implementation of
the forward propagation for all M
training examples at the same time so to
summarize you've just seen how you can
use vectorization to very efficiently
compute all the activations all the
lowercase a's so that at the same time
next it turns out you can also use
vectorization to very efficiently
compute the backward propagation to
compute the gradient let's see how you
can do that in the next video